hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Monster Hunter
roldugin and today we're gonna be
continuing with the solo guides of
Monster Hunter World and today we're
gonna be talking about Val Kanna one of
the elder dragons that's going to be
releasing with Monster Hunter World
ice-born so his eyes like to be if you
doing joy subscribe before he knew I
covered the solo guides of monster on
our world so it's always like the V if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
covered the solo guides a Monster Hunter
world I've covered a lot of the monsters
and what a lot of the higher tier
monsters and the base game and I'm going
to be covering a good majority of the
monsters in ice-born so definitely be on
the lookout for that if you guys want
some extra guys maybe some small little
bits of info they maybe didn't know or
you're super stuck in a monster and just
kind of want to proceed with the game
that if we stick around with the channel
for that with all that info out of the
way my Twitter and discord will be in
the description down below and let's get
started so as I stated today is going to
be a guide on Val kana this footage it
was taken during the beta if this video
is still up and you're watching this
that means Val kana from the beta to
launch didn't change at all and it is
the exact same monster we fought or
barely changed and wasn't really worth
it making a whole new video for meaning
the guide is still off today so do not
worry about that I will only be covering
his moves as a monster not the
surrounding environment as much since
I've seen a lot of gameplay from other
people and I've noticed that you can
actually fight him in different regions
so that really doesn't necessarily
matter just your game sense on what you
remember from each of the areas in the
ancient forest whether it be falling
boulders somewhere or there's some type
of pod that you need to grab or flash
bugs or stuff like that that's all down
to just muscle memory and what you
remember for the regions not necessarily
important for the fight although some of
it may also be important and also
remember that Val kana is an icy very
mean elder dragon which means because
he's an elder dragon you cannot use
traps poison paralysis falling boulders
all that stuff still works but traps do
not so keep that in mind so if you do
have any in your inventory don't use
them or just take them out of your
inventory in general it'll save you a
lot of time because they're not gonna
work
so volcano has a nice handful of moves
within the game two of them are almost
three of them if you want to consider
that our has the moves that are
considered ice breath one is a very
short-range one where he puts up a wall
of ice and then the other is a very long
range type of ice breath where he sprays
ICU very similar to ball
socks except a lot wider and a lot
faster than waha socks from testing
there really isn't much of a difference
between these two moves to determine
which one is being thrown at you first
other than noticing if he makes a wall
or not so definitely keep an eye on that
the spray usually goes from right to
left if you're within his perspective
but usually since you're going to be
fighting him it will be going from your
left to your right if you want to think
of it that way so run to his left or
your right and can go as close to him as
possible to close that gap do be aware
if you're a long range this move may
come multiple time so definitely do be
aware I've been in certain situations
where he's thrown the ice breath and
then doing done it right back and even
done it a third time so do be aware if
you are going to be called with the ice
breath I would just go straight towards
him immediately obviously dodging the
ice breath when it comes in but trying
to get as close as him as you can
possible so that it doesn't have to do
it multiple times I've also noticed a
slight variation of the ice breath which
is a lot quicker and a more forward
approach this breath is very similar to
the previous ones we've talked about
except it's the quickest one but it's
only straight and doesn't move I notice
this a lot not really sure when this
procs like I said there there's very
different there might be very different
stipulations it might be just based off
of long range but do be aware if you are
at a longer range you will either be
getting the one that sweeps and it's
kind of slow but somewhat still fast
because it is you know the wider
sweeping move or the one that it looks
like a basically a stray bullet that
goes right for you and you often dodge
that very quickly so do be aware for
that it also has a bunch of moves where
he gets up in the air
this one is a straightforward one if it
is a more straightforward and faster
movement he's going to be going for a
tail stab a simple stab with his tail
very straightforward there he can stab
you from the side or in front of you
just do the opposite of whatever comes
up meaning if he'd if he tries to stab
you from the side dodged forward closer
to him or if he stabs forward and then
dodge to the side and then of course run
up him and get some free hits there is a
small chance he will stab you again
afterwards so definitely make sure to
watch that once again not really sure
what the conditions are I because I've
been in certain scenarios where he's hit
me once and then hit me a second time or
but I've also been in situations where
he hasn't hit me the first time and
still thrown the second to try to get
that second chance so it just happens
sometimes it happened
if he fights if you fly straight up
softly there's another set of moves as
well you can tell by the AoE circle that
happens to appear letting you know where
the attack is and they should move away
quickly the first is an AoE ice wall the
ice will form on the ground thence prop
up from underneath going from inside out
as seen on screen there is a small
Center where he does spray the ice and
it is unconfirmed if you can actually
hide in the middle without taking damage
but I'm fairly certain you cannot
because that's actually where he sprays
the ice and I would assume that you
would take damage from that ice and then
the other ice when it comes up from the
ground anyways you're gonna be getting
hitting twice and it's probably not a
good idea especially when you're
fighting an elder dragon so I would just
stick away and try to go as far away as
you can but not too far because then you
might do that ice breath right back
you can also fly up and somewhat
recharge I guess if you want to call it
it as a little scream miss a twist and
kind of throws his wings out in the air
it seems that basically it seems like he
basically uses this to get his icy tips
back on his wings so others I feel like
this is where the Eldar show is going to
come in handy it still needs a lot more
testing but I do believe that this is
what elder SIA will affect whether or
not he's going to have those icy tips
which means he will be doing a lot more
a lot less damage and more of these
giant moves that require him to be up in
the air and stuff like that the other
the other variations of AoE moves are
the icicles the icicle will spawn on top
of you and hit you on the head you could
simply run away from this this isn't
really too much of a high damaging move
obviously but of course you don't want
to get hit by this stuff because you
could always be combo'd up afterwards so
just run away whenever you see that
stuff it's really not hard to see it
it's a little white cloud of ice above
your head letting you know if there's an
icicle coming down so just run in any
direction as long as you're not standing
still you should be completely a-ok
flash pods do work during this section
with volcano and button he will become
stunned or maybe give you a free hit but
he gets right back up and spams his ice
breath attack in a random direction so
may or may not be worth it depending on
your weapons if you have a faster weapon
of course maybe I'll get in two or three
hits before he gets back up the larger
weapons might not beginning a lot more
hits but they might be racking up a lot
more damage it is on a weapon to weapon
basis but do be aware if you're going to
flash pot him because try not to do
something that will keep you when they
move like the demons blade with the dual
blades because that stuff is going to
keep
you in there for a very long time and
you're gonna get smoked instantly as
soon as he gets back up one last little
thing in terms of moves and stuff is
that most of these will cause ice blight
which will drain your stamina super hard
and requires a no barre to get rid of so
definitely keep those in your inventory
when you fight him so as I said for some
last tidbits of information to remember
like I said keep the no berries on hand
for the ice blade I also read that if
you have 20 points in ice resistance
that will work - that does require a lot
of your gear being ice resistant but it
can help because instead of just
propping and popping it no Barre you can
just completely tank through it and not
have to worry and that's less time that
you have to deal with popping stuff when
you could be getting extra damage
like I said eldershield may or may not
work on Belconnen because he is an elder
dragon nothing has been confirmed
exactly what prevents or what it halts
but I'm like I'm saying it's either
going to be the ice surrounding the
arena it's going to be a lot less ice or
a less chance of doing those deadly
moves with those icy wing tips like I
stated previously in terms of Mantle's
and other boosters you want to bring now
with the new recent update of ice born
there is ice proof mantle plus a ghillie
mantle plus allowing you to put certain
decorations in your slots for Mantle's
not the health booster sadly or the
affinity booster I believe but the other
mantle is you can put boots on so that
is entirely up to you but you want to
add button just from the base mantle
without any slots on it I would
recommend ice proof that's going to help
you out a lot the ice mantle is gonna be
great and of course the temporal mantle
and Rocksteady you can never go wrong
with those what if you're a lot more
confident you can always get a health
booster an infinity booster and kill him
a lot quicker but I would recommend the
ice one just to kind of you'd slide into
things a lot more easily via overall val
connor really isn't that impossible if I
definitely a challenge it was an
excellent battle and very rewarding when
I finally beat it but like I said
volcana is not impossible or the
developers want to add it the monster in
the first place so obviously with this
guide hopefully that does help you as
usual if you have any other tidbits of
information that maybe I missed or I
didn't explain in better detail let me
know in the comments below and I can try
to compile this list I also try to check
my pin comment down below in the day on
the comments section because there might
be a lot more info from the comment
section that I want to
coorporate and one other post Eston I
have it scattered and have you looking
for 2 to 3 minutes so that all the info
is displayed right there for you to look
at guys as always like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe for free new I covered
the solo guides of monster on our world
I'm gonna be covering a lot more of the
characters and ice-born as I stated
previously so if you do want to help
with it maybe some maybe a little bit of
information that you may not have known
about the monsters in ice-born or if
you're stuck on a monster entirely I'll
be there to help you guys out yeah I
guess I'd like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new my Twitter in
discord will be in the description down
below if you guys want to join that and
join the community that'd be greatly
appreciated and with that take care guys
have a great astir day hopefully you
guys are enjoying ice-born or if it's
during the beta hope you guys enjoyed
the beta and peace out take care however
yesterday
[Music]
you
[Music]